ladies and gentlemen one of the biggest
political stories of the year of the
decade of the entire time that i've been
covering politics took place last night
august 8th the anniversary of the
resignation of president richard nixon
from his office
the fbi executed a search warrant at
donald trump's home mar-a-lago including
a search of his personal quarters as
well as of a safe it is an incredible
situation this all happening in
connection with donald trump taking
those massive dumps of classified
documents to his own house
nbc reporting fbi search at trump's
mar-a-lago home tied to classified
material in a lengthy statement monday
night trump said they even broke into my
safe former president trump said monday
the fbi raided his home at mar-a-lago
and cracked his safe a source familiar
with the matter said to nbc news it was
all tied to the classified information
that donald trump took with him from the
white house in january of 2021.
this is an extraordinary situation the
claims being made by those on the right
are beyond parody and we will get to
that but first and foremost donald
trump's own reaction to this putting out
an unhinged statement
saying the following
these are dark times
for our nation as my beautiful home
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida is
currently under siege raided and
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
nothing like this has ever happened to a
president of the united states before
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessary or appropriate the fact that
trump is saying he was cooperating to me
suggests he wasn't because he basically
lies about everything it is a
prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the justice system and
an attack by radical left democrats who
desperately don't want me to run for
president in 2024 especially based on
recent polls now remember the current
director of the fbi is christopher wray
appointed by donald trump so to claim
that this is the work of far-left
democrats it is being asserted without
evidence and until evidence is presented
i believe we can dismiss it as there is
no evidence
trump going on to say such an assault
could only take place in broken third
world countries sadly america has now
become one of those capital c countries
corrupt at a level not seen before
wow they even broke into my safe
what is the difference between this and
watergate where operatives broke into
the dnc here in reverse democrats broke
into the home of the 45th president of
the united states big massive dumps well
that's all going to remain to be seen i
do hope given trump's propensity to
flush evidence down the toilet i hope
the fbi has plumbers on staff and that
they have appropriate elements of
plumbing with suction in order to figure
out what on earth did trump flush down
that toilet what records did he destroy
so trump blaming this on the radical
left the truth is trump selected the fbi
director who would have had to sign off
on this and just as a reminder here is
donald trump praising the great
christopher wray from the fbi president
trump is just tweeting about the fbi
director here's what he says i will be
nominating christopher a ray a man of
impeccable credentials to be the next
director of the fbi details to follow
right that's the guy now that trump is
saying
is the radical left
going after him now understand such a
decision to raid the house of a former
president
it must have been approved by the
attorney general merrick garland
the top echelon of the fbi must have
known about it that is one very bad news
for donald trump and second
you don't do this on a whim
the fbi also would have required
probable cause
to have a belief that there were
specific places again trump's personal
quarters trump safe they would have to
have probable cause to be able to say
here's where we want to search
it wouldn't be a shock
if a very high-level trump associate
flipped and was cooperating with the fbi
we don't know that but for them to have
such probable cause about the specific
places in trump's home to be searched
could it have been mark meadows we don't
know it's all speculative but the most
important part of this is that when
trump says they broke into my safe and
later you'll hear eric trump say there
was nothing in it which is interesting
they would need some reason to include
the safe as a search location they would
have some reason to think that the safe
might have a nexus to potentially
criminal activity now if the raid was
only about some low-level staffer and
not about trump or someone near trump
it's unlikely they would go into his
personal safe again we're reading tea
leaves and speculating based on what we
do know
um they couldn't have done this
if they didn't have a good case to do it
and that the belief at least the
plausible belief that mar-a-lago
contained evidence of criminal activity
now attorney mark elias pointed out
the media is missing the really big
reason why the raid is a potential
blockbuster in american politics and
that relates to
18 u.s code subsection 2071 the
concealment removal and mutilation
generally and it says
that if indeed one is found guilty of
mishandling documents in this way
concealing removing mutilating
obliterating
the penalty is forfeiture of public
office and disqualification from holding
any office under the united states
that's potentially what is at play here
assuming that this involves the
mishandling or unauthorized removal of
classified information and if they find
those elements at mar-a-lago
the substance of the documents is less
important it's the fact that they were
classified and that they were improperly
removed their presence alone would be
indicative of this crime now again we're
going to get to clips in a moment of all
the people saying everything done was
improper
uh merrick garland would not have
authorized this and a federal judge
would not have okayed it if there was
not significant evidence to warrant it
and recall with hillary clinton's case
the doj didn't prosecute because she may
have been negligent with information
maybe she was even reckless but it was
not an intentional mishandling that rose
to criminality and if this is what
happened at mar-a-lago we have to
believe that at least potentially that
is what the fbi believes donald trump
did
one of our longtime sponsors splendid
spoon is giving you 50
off as many of you know i am not
vegetarian but i think eating
plant-based
is a great thing and i do more of it
consciously
splendid spoon takes the work out of
eating plant-based by delivering
ready-to-eat plant-based meals smoothies
and juices right to your door splendid
spoon fits into my day easily the meals
are in my fridge put them on the
stovetop or in the microwave and i've
got a great fresh plant-based meal in a
few minutes it saves me time which is
really useful right now whether you're
vegan or you just want to add an easy
delicious way to have more plants in
your diet splendid spoon is a great way
to go
there are great dishes like creamy
mushroom and spinach noodles coconut
curry cauliflower tikka soup that's one
of my favorites tons of choices the menu
rotates constantly i've tried a lot of
different meal subscription services
splendid spoon is great on both taste
and quality they pack so much flavor
into the dishes they taste freshly
cooked splendid spoons smoothies are
awesome when i'm on the go and you'll
get fifty dollars off your first week
when you subscribe at
splendidspoon.com pacman the link is
down below